[MUSIC PLAYING]
You know, I love this
idea of radical openness,
the free exchange
of information,
the free flow of ideas, creating
spaces in which ideas can have
sex, as Matt Ridley talks about.
And this is huge because it
turns out that ideas are just
as real as the
neurons they inhabit,
as James Gleick tells us.
A new kingdom rises
above the biosphere.
Denizens of this
kingdom are ideas,
because ideas have retained some
of the properties of organisms,
it turns out.
They leap from brain to brain.
They compete for the limited
resources of our attention.
They have infectivity.
They have spreading power.
They are, what
Richard Dawkins calls,
the new replicators, born
from the primordial soup
of human culture.
Their vector of
transmission is language
and electronic communication.
And though ideas are
made of nucleic acid,
they have achieved more
evolutionary change
and at a rate that leaves the
old gene panting far behind.
You know, Ray Kurzweil
says our ability
to create virtual
models in our heads,
combined with our
modest-looking thumbs,
was sufficient to usher in the
secondary force of evolution
called technology.
And it will continue,
until the entire universe
is at our fingertips.
This is unbelievable stuff.
It speaks to the telescopic
nature of evolutionary change,
more change in
the last 100 years
than in the last billion years.
Terrance McKenna actually
wrote, "from the moment
that human beings
invented language,
biological evolution
essentially ceased,
and evolution became a cultural
epigenetic phenomenon."
Now, we take in matter
of low organization,
we put it through
our mental filters,
and we extrude it in the form
of space shuttles and iPhones.
You know, the
imaginary foundation
tells us that what
imagination does
is it allows us to conceive
of delightful future
possibilities, pick
the most amazing one,
and pull the present
forward to meet it.
Imagine how
impoverished this world
would have been, if
we hadn't invented
the technology of the oil
painting in time for Van Gogh,
or the technology of the
musical instrument in time
for Beethoven and Mozart
to unfurl through it.
With the revolutions
in biotechnology
and nanotechnology, the
free exchange of information
is allowing us to conceive
of radical new things.
Freeman Dyson says,
in the future,
a new generation of artists
will be writing genomes
with the fluency that Blake
and Byron wrote verses.
"What is great in
man," said Nietzsche,
"is that he is a
bridge and not an end."
"We're on a trajectory smack
in the middle between born
and and the made,"
wrote Kevin Kelly.
And so radical
openness, it's huge.
It's a universe of possibility.
It's gray infused by color.
It's the invisible revealed.
It's the mundane
blown away by awe.
We need to cultivate
radical openness
as a way of participating
and accelerating evolution.
Wow.
[MUSIC PLAYING]